hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and I'm John Humphrey we are going to do
another video podcast movie review of a
classic film called Lost Horizon which
is kind of a lost classic film usually I
tell people lately is a Frank Capra
movie a guy who did the director of it
happened one night the Pinet yeah
Punisher and they get the joke at verse
it was poorly inserted I get it now John
and it's he also did mr. deeds goes to
Washington and then this movie was one
of those so I forget the exact history
of how a lot of this went down that's
actually explained on the blu-ray that
we have my girlfriend Olivia is very
much familiar with this time in history
of like there was a time where some
studios I think was in multiple studios
I could be wrong feel free to correct me
with hatred pure hatred George it is
about how there's a like lot of film
reels that were just burnt and and then
from according to it's been a few weeks
as I've seen the movie but I think the
text at the beginning was saying that it
was UCLA and Sony Pictures work together
on restoring this film and it looks
great yeah there are some moments in
here where it's just
stills because they couldn't
successfully restore it but they had the
whole soundtrack yeah so they have the
whole audio throughout and for the very
there's only a few minutes like
literally out of a two hour and 13
minutes there's only a few minutes that
it's just stills yeah so for most of it
it's all back here yeah and this is
theoretically the most comprehensive cut
that exists now because there have been
many cuts over time with this movies
some ranging from like you know a little
over an hour and a half to this one
that's like slightly over two hours so
there's a lot that's been added oh yeah
end of this and I I do want if you
happen to make it at this point of the
video I would like to encourage you guys
to actually you know listen to what
we're going to talk about cuz if you
haven't even seen the movie and we will
go into some spoilers I think that's
okay I'm gonna reveal something that
I've never done this before we see a
while ago we watched a movie a movie a
youtube video call from a guy
it's Tyler why I'm not afraid of
spoilers and in it he talked about how
he sometimes will like go on Wikipedia
or something and then read the
description of the plot and then watch
the movie and at the time when I watched
this I was kind of in a really tired
state and adjusting my mind a classic
films can sometimes be a little bit
rougher for me and just from my
mentality to be fully absorbed so I read
the plot description for this and I
forgot most of it and honestly it's one
of those films that when you read the
plot description it's still confusing
you're like I don't even really
understand it I don't even get what I
just read yeah it's such a weird movie
that when I read it I'm like okay I
think I got it
alright so even when I watched this I
was still very much surprised by so much
that happens in this movie and so my
point to that is that even if we spoil
this film for you guys I think you can
go back and watch it and still heavily
appreciate this movie it's a 1937 film
it's not one of those twists and so
there's like one big reveal at the end
yeah but other than that it's still you
know it's up to you if you want to stick
around - her knee is worth it absolutely
because the details of the beauty of the
swimmer in the journey one of our top
reporters on patreon is whatever video
anyone requests whether that be a
discussion podcast of sorts or a
reaction we will do and put up on
YouTube assuming he doesn't get blocked
out reaction and today comes from our
dear dear friend David Gandy love you
man and he actually said we did Maltese
Falcon and he sent that DVD over to us
the blu-ray and now he introduced us to
this movie so not only is he one of our
top reward top pledges on patreon a dear
friend he's also sending us classic
blu-rays yeah getting our film education
you know he's sending us his account and
routing number so we can just steal from
him directly and we just write ourselves
checks buy all the DVDs we want the film
equipment upgrades it's thank you for
lending us your money library has really
so this movie Lost Horizon 1937 film and
I got to tell you guys I it's not often
I watch a class especially moved from
this time period that watch one and I
find myself halfway going I think I love
this movie
yeah and I genuinely love this movie
because that had been a few weeks I went
back and went through went to three
specific scenes in this film because
there was a couple things I wanted to
write down and I just found myself like
as I was writing out notices like
watching it again it's like damn I it's
really is like just a really good movie
yeah it has an aura about it that really
is easy to get sucked into especially
just due to what the film itself is
about like you're being brought into
through the characters this fantastical
utopian world and like it is really easy
to be dazzled by that even if you know
it is much older and Sensibility and you
know it's black/white it's stuff like if
you've seen the movie or if you haven't
just IMDB a list the plot description oh
is really from IMDB because those
professionals who are hired to write a
intriguing log line so it's not me just
being lazy it's just it's the best there
is so much
yeah and it says a plane crash delivers
a group of people to the secluded land
of shangri-la which are things I made up
work but is the miraculous but is it the
miraculous utopia it appears to be fun
fact shangri-la is like you know it's a
town in LA that is just you know it's a
word that you've probably heard thrown
around a million times that just you
know sort of as a stand-in for any sort
of miraculous utopian place
oh is it I yeah yeah that's the word
that's a sort of seep its way into
culture and I didn't realize when
watching this that this the book and you
know the movie by proxy is where that
term comes from oh I I thought it was
just a term that existed but it's from
this source material well it's one of
the theatres of the thousands upon
thousands of films that have come
the u.s. is one of the few films that is
in the National Film registry the
Godfather's in this is part of the
National Film registry at the Library of
Congress for culturally historically or
aesthetically significant in history so
it goes to show you the importance of
this movie and so the main character in
this film is a man played by Robert
Conway and the character is named the
same first letter so it's kind of
confusing I've read it wrong Russ I mean
Ronald Coleman is the character as actor
and a character he plays is a man named
Robert Conway
it's the RC part of it like which one is
it yeah really easy to keep all the
monogrammed props that hurts
yes so in the beginning of this movie
he's basically in China and he has a
mission to rescue 90 Americans or
Westerners in the city of best school
and he's set to become the new foreign
secretary yeah he's he's basically
bringing a bunch of British nationals
back so that he can you know a rescue
them and be take his place as you know a
diplomat yeah
and so at the beginning of this movie
already I was already impressed from the
very beginning because for a 1930s movie
when you when you look a lot of times
well surprise me is budget with these
films and then you you kind of get
thrown into this like chaotic situation
which looking back at the film is a
brilliant setup of setting you in this
time where there's so much chaos in this
specific part of the world where he has
to rescue these people and you're
looking at it and it's like wow look at
all these extras there's so many extras
it's so many and nowadays you get a lot
of digitalize you know extras which is a
good way to save money and probably
healthier for everyone involved - or
actual background actors because when
you see movies like this I always start
to question it because there's several
scenes in here - with with good with
amount of extras or non-american actors
where I tend to go where these guys paid
yeah
and in the show in the beginning of the
movie immediately it says something like
real the anxious state and the manor the
main character that Robert Coleman plays
who's fantastic in this movie I'll say
what part of why I loved it is because
for a film that's from like what I'm not
doing math well like 90 years ago so
yeah from that long ago it felt
surprisingly modern and I couldn't tell
if like when they restored it if they
decided to you know do a little bit more
editing then I researched it a little
bit more today and I'm that that's just
how they shot it Frank Capra went
through a lot of film on this movie this
film when examle over budget and was
considered a financial disaster when it
first came out because normally when you
watch movies from this time period even
as other films like it happened one
night for example there's not a lot of
cutting it's usually heavily reliant on
the screenplay
and the two and then usually the male of
the the leads it's usually the leads
that it that it's relied on like the
performances and the writing and the end
directing is fairly simple in terms of
camera angles and in the first act of
this movie you're primarily on this on
the plane that's leaving the that's
leaving China yeah and this is where you
get to know the main characters our main
character who's like really unsatisfied
with life even though he's doing very
well he's got a real repressed sarcastic
sense of humor I don't know why identify
with this guy so he really suppressed
since it so he's very charming he's very
funny he has a brother I'm assuming a
younger one who really looks up to him
and then in the plane you start to get
to know the rest of the ensemble at
least their personalities yeah yeah and
immediately a few things I really
noticed was the script the script very
solid very energetic and every one of
these characters has a very distinct
voice which I always appreciate in films
today but for back then especially where
it's not all hey I don't have ID about
that
like everyone had a very everyone has a
sense of mystery behind them specific
purposes for what they were doing
specific backgrounds and I mean being
adapted from a novel lends itself to
that advantage but to see it translated
as script to a screen was was
beautifully done and I especially
noticed that with us with a lot of the
the first act but I'm really taking
place in this plane there's a lot of
different angles there's a lot of
specific choice of symmetry here there's
a lot of specific editing that goes on
in here
yeah actually had to think like okay how
can we make this one pretty cramped
space still engaging still have rhythm
with the tone of the dialogue and all
that stuff because there is a lot of
character internally that's happening
and that's kind of what carries the
first chunk of the movie because it's
also you know vitally important once
they get to shangri-la where everybody
comes from and what all their
sensibilities are because everybody kind
of gets tested by what shangri-la is to
begin with yes because leading up to
shangri-la prize what happens is you you
start to discover that their pilot is
actually one is it [ __ ] yeah yeah
their planes basically been like
hijacked and they don't exactly know why
and they can't communicate to the pilot
yeah and one days portrayed is like a
villain yeah and you know he's got his
gun yeah well cuz he's kidnapped them I
feel like yeah there's a shot in the
beginning where they like pan up to the
cockpit window and he's like strangling
the original islet and stuff like that
so it's building up this mystery in this
darkness and then they could the plane
crashes in like the Himalayan mountains
or something and and then the pilots
dead here so you're really setting up
for a kind of a dark stranded mystery
adventure and it's not long and a hidden
because of Robert Coleman's or Robert
Ronald Ronald Coleman is the actor
Robert Conway I'm just go on calmly
alright Khan would Conway the character
Conway takes it upon himself to you know
he has to lead this
like lead the people here who are all in
a state of panic right now and they're
most likely gonna die and then really
soon after there's a bunch of people who
look like natives of this land
yeah there's basically like a little
train of people who come out and find
them who look kind of like they expected
yeah you know why they're not they're
not just a bunch of Caucasian people no
not even sure exactly what ethnicity I
think it supposed to imply they're
Chinese though and but but the main guy
led by them is a man named Chang played
by HB Warner who is also amazing in this
movie the to stand out to me are the
lead con wek the character P and and
Chang the character yeah so then they're
taking on this journey going through the
mountains in this hidden land this
hidden utopia of sorts called shangri-la
which is a very peaceful place and when
you get there is everyone's is very
peaceful but of course the people going
into this land are characters and like
the West Westerners trained to be
suspicious what is this weird society
they have going on
could any of this be true have we been
kidnapped for a reason is this is some
kind of happenstance so it really sets
you up for this very very dark mystery
and probably some crazy unraveling of
evil that's really at play here because
you're in the mindset of the Westerners
yeah in this moment because as you're
primarily everyone's very suspicious you
know everyone's suspicious and on guard
and there's one person who's curious and
intrigued by the mystery of it all and
that's our main character which makes it
so delightful throughout the film he is
the one guy who's like I don't know I
think this is pretty cool yeah I'm gonna
check it all I know you guys can be as
grumpy as you want he wants to learn
more there's this hidden world and the
production design of it even for just
looking at it
in the format now there's four 1930s
film you're like man they build this is
this this is crazy how they I kept
asking myself nowadays II see something
like that and it's easy to fathom like
oh here's how probably have they made
this back then you go how what how do
they make this boom was fairly new who
you know color in movies was just being
introduced Tina like how did they put
this together well and some of that I
mean I know the valley itself that
shangri-la is is actually they shot that
up in Ojai Valley can hour and a half or
so away from here
thank you visit shangri-la in California
you probably sure can I mean I don't
know if the if the actual like palatial
structures that I'm like Cheng and and
the llama or in you know the basically
the place where they're all Center I
don't that is there but I know the
actual valley itself mmm-hmm and then as
the film unfolds basically what starts
to happen when they're here is a lot of
the Westerners excluding one guy who is
the brother of Conway the Westerners
start to you know they're they have
their suspicions but then little little
things just real simple nature things of
life start to make them adjust to here
what started off as a place where
they're stranded and then they're
rescued starts to feel like they're
kidnapped yet they're adjusting to the
lifestyle
well yeah cuz they're brought into this
place and it's you know obviously
foreign but what starts to happen is you
know they have these rituals and they
have this claim basically that here in
shangri-la we have this society that is
very much based on merit and and
moderation and whatnot and we also have
just like I don't know just this aura of
health it's like you don't deteriorate
here
yeah and that's a lot for everybody to
kind of take in but over time you know
as the characters initially are opposed
they all start to come around to it in
their own way when they see something
come out of it that matches what they're
looking for but the movie does such a
good job of making you wonder okay yeah
but what's really up yeah yeah yeah okay
what's really yuck so what happened
really
like what when the movie really started
a hardcore connect with me was when I
started realizing how much deeper this
movie is and this is when I went to that
there's this there's a good chunk of the
movie like it's like 10 to 15 solid
minutes of this where Conway is being
educated on the history of shangri-la
that there was a there was like a priest
I believe who eventually becomes a high
high Lama of him who basically found the
land built this utopia lived to be like
200 years old and when he was there so
basically so basically when he was sorry
I'm trying to look at my notes here so
now that they have this utopia there and
then they start talking about that they
live on a principle of moderation
because Conway as a man who's fasting
about this wants to know a little bit
more about it and then as he's learning
about it they say we like what are your
religious beliefs you know basically ask
none other Western cultures how do you
live how do you make money what do you
do about people who are you know
behaving on a hand you have a jail
system soldiers security what about all
these things and Chang the reason I love
his performance so much in this is
because he's so matter-of-fact about
everything he's just so sincere they're
both very sincere performers on two
different levels because the guy who
plays Chang easily could have taken the
approach of act a little suspicious but
he doesn't yeah it's just so like warm
yeah everything he's very calm about
everything and just kind of eerily
reassuring all the time you know he then
they start talking about their
philosophies and this becomes into a
full of Safa chol discussion that's when
I started going wow this movies because
he's asked like what are your religious
practices and he says Chang says we
practice moderation and everything's
just about moderation and there's like
well what makes a criminal lack envy
there can be no crime when there is a
sufficiency of everything and how a
little courtesy all around helps us
smooth out even the biggest of problems
so when they're talking about that
element they start going into a little
bit more of things because even when
they're talking about how when they get
food supplies which happens over the
course of several years
they that they don't call it buy and
sell they just call it exchange it's
like little tweaks and vocabulary about
perspective and they're talking about
where they're at in the climate that
because of the kind of water they have
that there are a lot healthier they're
able to live for longer they're talking
about how the way they live is primarily
based off of the absence of struggle and
then he starts talking about Westerner
quotes like have you ever heard the
quote he worries himself to death which
is a popular Western quote and there's
there was one line here and I went
through the movie to make sure I wrote
it down correctly where Chang says the
Westerners lives are shorter not so much
by natural death but by indirect suicide
because everything is primarily how we
take care of ourselves physically
emotionally and mentally and that's
pretty much what shangri-la does well as
they do call that very well why they can
live for longer and no real scientific
basis las Aafia bout it yeah it's like a
place where everybody exists in total
harmony and there is no major unrest or
disease of any kind yeah exactly because
what is disease when the body is not at
ease and this movie heavily plays into
that philosophy so what was interesting
about it is as the movie keeps going you
get to a point where you're like
nothing's anything over this place yeah
I think yeah I think it's just as good
as they're going but there's gotta be
some kind of conflict or something cuz
oh my [ __ ] that's my Western mentality
you're right there's like a great place
maybe for an American movie to do that
to make me go know I'm like oh [ __ ] I'm
these guys it's like yeah it puts you in
the position because I think that's a
brilliant thing about this movie in the
way it'll probably hit a lot of people
yeah just naturally you're suspicious
yeah getting to know all this stuff
especially when you hear how great it is
and also to their the element of fantasy
that plays in when they're like you know
this person's been here since 1880
whatever you know they must be it's
supremely old and it's those things that
play in your mind and make you go I know
something's gotta be up here and that's
kind of a brilliant element to this
movie especially the way it unfolds
toward the end you know
when it actually does something about
that expectation for you to in my life
today I've recently discovered some
audio of a speaker named simon Sinek
which is kind of a funny last name for a
guy who's so positive and he's like an
idealist and he really he really strives
for helping to develop a future where
people love going to work were employers
and CEOs and all that are really about
you know taking care of their employees
and really you know taking care of the
people around you it sounds like very
corny cliche stuff but if you live a
dive into more details about it you
start to see that it was really his
perception of trying to form the world
and in the movie
Conway eventually gets to meet the Dalai
Lama it comes to find out he's alive and
by the way it's great it's a great
sequence because it's like people people
are early on in the movie before
everyone starts adjusting and only
calmly someone adjusting to this and
wants to stay here everyone else is like
we gotta get out of here there's
something wrong I don't want to go back
to my hometown you know everyone's like
I'm dying I gotta get out of here ya
know the one the guy who plays uncle
Billy and it's a wonderful life maybe
doesn't want to leave but you know then
you've got the archeologist who's like
stuff being scared all the time and
everybody has a reason they need to go
so Chang decides to let him meet the
Dalai Lama come to find out this is the
guy who the high Lamas are yeah well it
seems I'm inspired by yeah so when it
comes time to meet him he finds out it's
the guy who is the he's the priest to
Kay's priests to found this he's 200
years old now and comes across a little
creepy because he's 200 years old but
he's really a nice guy and they're great
at making him seem like he is like
extremely old without but and doing well
for exactly without you know at least
the advanced makeup and effects
capabilities we have now and in that way
he does convincingly come across as this
sort of ethereal aged being yeah and I
love the way the sequence was shot
because when Conway first walks in they
just keep doing two shots like one
should not see shot single shots one
shot of Conway one shot of this guy and
then once Conway
realises that this is the guy who found
it then they then they go to this
two-shot and that's when they decide to
do the master shot at them and it was
like a candle in between them and this
is in this dark room yeah like I don't
know something how you want to interpret
it but something about lumen ating life
and it's between yeah exactly and it was
beautifully done let's I mean there's a
lot of intentional cinematography here a
lot of very specific shots here and I I
guess in a weird way it's it's sort of
an inspiring movie like you started
going through a lot of plot elements not
gonna anything that we've worked on a
lot of like will led to a lot of these
moments because well started sort of
happening I'll give you like some basic
Wikipedia kind of breakdown of it
eventually the brother he really wants
to get out there's this woman there who
has been living there for a while and
but she's not she wasn't born there
everyone who's basically born there
doesn't have a desire to leave because
this is a place that's really it not
about desire or struggle or trying to
achieve success or whatever everything's
very equal oh yeah exactly there's no
use for any of that so they're gonna
live forever because they don't have
this [ __ ] worry you know there's like
things I don't like man I'd be great man
and instead of making youtube videos so
eventually because he's kind of torn
between the the the high Lama wants a
con way to take over and be the new
leader because he's an author Conway
he's written in all these books well and
this matches directly with what he wants
out of life and actually I read there's
a speech that he gives in this movie
about being tired of all these basically
all the Western concerns being like
tired of money and going out and even
though he's so popular and so successful
this isn't a fulfilling life for him and
so he plays you know all of shangri-la
plays to that and there's a speech he
gives about that idea that being sick of
you know his life back home that's so
great that they took out they took out
originally and then put back in yeah
Studios kept trimming this movie yeah
over six hours
I mean fair enough but that but that is
sort of a thesis of this movie that does
help a lot because yeah a lot of it is
them playing to that side of him where
it's like this is the kind of life you
want to be living truly yeah and you are
the person to carry it on for us because
of that yeah exactly
cuz the high Lama has some really
powerful speeches too that are very deep
this is one moment there he's talking
along the lines of you know how weapons
will evolve
which they did and unintelligible
leadership and he's talking about how
the Christian belief will one day be
fulfilled when the strong have devour
one another we'll all have to live by
one principle a very simple one of be
kind be loving to one another and so the
meek shall inherit the earth basically
is what they're getting at here and
shangri-la is this attempt to basically
at this moment in time take all of the
most you know precious or you know
qualitative things and and preserve them
here until such a time as that comes to
pass and then we can bring the whole
world in yeah it's like they're like the
guy who's the archaeologist he
discovered something at the begin the
movie they want to bring back to his
home country so you can I try to win a
Nobel Prize and all that [ __ ] and then
he discovers that he'd rather just stay
here and be a teacher to these children
you know really educate them teach about
geology yeah and then there's a there's
an escape another scam are to con are
yeah no no the swindler yeah he's he's
there and he's like well I mean if I go
back home I'm just gonna get arrested
and stuff well yeah then he he comes
because he initially wants to steal gold
yeah it finds out that there the
shangri-la has a high amount of gold and
that's how they make their exchanges so
or more food and stuff because they
don't really care for the gold yeah yeah
and he's like yeah I get something cold
yeah and then eventually even he comes
around he's like I've got this whole
plumbing system we're gonna happen
running water down to the bottom gonna
be great you know it and and Gloria
who's the woman he's not really much of
to be that much of a character but she
is terminally ill and then even she
comes around she's like I feel better
she and the swindler guy are actually
getting along like making plans together
and stuff but then there's the brother
who wants no part of this
and then he he starts
yeah relationship with one of the women
who was not born there she was brought
she eventually found her way there and
then stayed there but she has this idea
because this is when the movie decides
to go yeah the woman who drops yeah
Maria Maria I think I'm that's the name
is coming to mind yeah Maria Maria when
she is if Maria and George and their
base Maria is basically the one
affirming George's beliefs of yeah
they're messed up here they're
manipulative dad basically all the
things you often hear about places that
are usually pretty positive yeah she
wants more you know she wants all the
things that basically are that that
she's kind of a representation of the of
all the the antithesis to the things
that they're talking about how
shangri-la well and the fact that even
in a place like this these ideas can
grow exact somebody can be discontent
with all this and because this is
Conway's brother he decides he's gonna
leave and which is not at all what he
wants there's a woman there who's the
reason why he's even brought there I was
introducing Sondra she's the main female
lead and she's basically just all about
you know Roberts 1930s woman Bernard and
well back then
for the most part all right but it plays
on an interesting at least with him and
the brother and the conflict there it
does play on something interesting
because you know George's whole point is
like you just let them you know entice
you with this promise of a utopia
without any real evidence but you know I
got this girl here who says like it's
completely [ __ ] up but they're kind of
doing the same thing because you realize
after a while he didn't really have a
ton of actual evidence either he just
had her word examine a Conway has you
know the lawmen and Chang's word and
tonight it's a battle for beliefs
exactly yeah
and that's fiction that's where a lot of
it just comes down to in this movie and
what I'll say is that the debates in the
movie are written very well because even
when he comes in and Maria come Georgia
Maria come in so then they end up
leaving the mountains is great reveal is
this one cuz like they're in this
secluded part of like shangri-la [ __ ]
hit it alright yeah
so then there's there's Outsiders who
think that people in shangri-la are
[ __ ] crazy
and yeah Porter's yeah the outsiders are
there helping them get back so that way
they can find their way back to their
home country and then along the journey
when they're encountering the dangers of
nature and the snows the blizzards yeah
at one point Conway is carrying this
[ __ ] it's carrying Maria the whiny girl
wanted to get out of shangri-la yeah and
then George is like wait look at her
face and yeah and this is great makeup
and his scare is actually like a scary
moment because she's [ __ ] old and
that's what that's what they were Chang
was warning her about like she can't
leave because she's gonna share her age
look at the climate they with the
weather everything is just gonna catch
up turned and then she's gonna just age
and die oh yeah well that's because
there was that beautiful thing where
you're the you know when he's being
introduced to all this he's talking to
Chang I think it is and he's like yeah
you know if she were to leave she would
just age to her appropriate age and
that's what would happen you know it's
now she leaves the boundaries of here
and it's just one of the little details
of how shangri-la works but it becomes
yeah this huge reveal and it was a good
visual reveal because that's the moment
where you go it's her death that makes
you go oh my god they were telling the
truth this woman was young and we are
stranded
yeah here with no porters nobody and
because of George is like I'm at so good
I was just like you just can't believe
any of this is her whole world flipped
upside down and he was kind of in in
this chick yeah he just kills himself
right there like right awaits [ __ ]
kill himself yeah and and then our main
character Conway is stranded is stranded
it's kind of a bummer it's a downer cuz
you're like man is gonna be one of those
endings
I was literally yelling at the TV I was
like no all that you're gonna make him
suffer
yeah I'm really do a convincing job with
that piece of the the movie cuz II they
it for a minute had me going that he's
just not getting he's gonna die in the
snow yeah shouldn't have let it's gonna
be a cautionary tale he shouldn't have
left you know and eventually he's found
by a Chinese mission where a search
party is looking for him then he's
brought back to it was this home guys in
America I could tell he was British or
American no this is all I believe UK
stuff because when they're getting on
the plane they're like we're the Queen's
royal subjects but yeah he's found by
like a Chinese mission and like is
initially gonna be transferred back and
then just like escapes you know well let
me break this down for you alright yeah
I want to read to you what wikipedia
says about it okay I'm gonna go into
this all right so it says the ordeal has
caused him to lose his memory of
shangri-la on the voyage back to England
he starts to remember everything he
tells the story then jump ship the
searchers track him back to the
Himalayas but I'm able to follow him any
further
stop right there is one more sentence
yeah what's funny about that
you don't see any of that where you what
you end up getting is I don't know what
care crew is but there's some guy who's
been trying to hunt this [ __ ]
down follow him he's always acted like
almost everybody this guy's always once
that bad and there's even way more to
this journey oh yeah this guy goes on a
tangent like I'm a [ __ ] monologue
talking about the journey that Conway
went on of the amount of being captured
and breaking out and having to do this
and having to do that he's going on for
a while where I'm like oh that'd be a
whole [ __ ] interesting movie I bet
that was probably part of the six hours
we're out of time for this [ __ ] like a
whole 40 minutes which made me go if I
were to ever remake Lost Horizon I
wouldn't remake Lost Horizon I would
just tell this moot I would just start
off with that this guy's brought back to
his home country he doesn't remember and
then he starts to remember then you kind
of have this perspective of this guy of
people going dude you're crazy that's
insane so it's his journey to get back
to this place like he believes is real
that no one else believes usually oh
then by the end of the movie you find
out oh [ __ ] it's real and I'm like that
would be my remake return so it's not
like redoing any of this movie it's just
telling the story that was just in a
[ __ ] monologue yeah cuz by the end of
the movie you you see Conway he's
traveling through the mountains and then
he sets his seizes eyes that sets his
eyes upon shangri-la one more time
showing he successfully made it back
yeah David Gandy did send me a question
of like do you do I think that it would
have been more effective or would have
been better if we didn't see him return
to shangri-la
and know I personally loved the choice
that you do see him Kant would have been
pissed I'm like ever all that and we're
like I just love to interpretation
whether he made it back you know I
thought they were gonna do it and and
after the reaction they got out of me
when I thought he was just gonna die in
the snow at that point I was like you
know what you've earned this I I'm
really glad that he made it but hey yeah
it's like he comes back with open arms
he's like look at me I'm the king you
know ya just seize it so you're like
okay he's made it back yeah there was an
alternate ending on the DVD that I
watched where it's roughly the same but
he comes back and Sandra's just there
waiting for him like waving so yeah I
appreciate that they just went with the
ending where he just finds it again
that's it ya know like romantic button
on it because like the cool thing about
this movie overall is there's so much
intrigue there's a lot of philosophy
about you know Western society and what
a utopia might look like but there's
also a ton of intrigue there's romance
there's action there is you know kind of
a sci-fi elements a fantasy fantasy it's
it's got this very grounded
yeah you mentioned earlier like feeling
like it wasn't very hard to slip into
this you know as a classic movie as an
older movie with older sensibilities and
I feel like yeah it really is of a
timeless variety of Hollywood movie that
has every kind of thing in it well I
mean for its time it was the most
expensive movie ever made at that point
and it just kind of shows and because
like the Frank capper like [ __ ] burns
through film you know I like this he
wasn't [ __ ] mad for a little while
after this and and like he like here's a
story behind it that I didn't know it's
a way after watching this movie of man
this guy a [ __ ] struggle with this
movie because it was it was a [ __ ]
failure at first and but when you watch
it you're like this feels like very
modern even just watching clips back I'm
like of course there's some of its 1930s
aesthetic stuff but the film is very
much like edited it's very much composed
and the acting is so good like there's
some damn good acting in this movie it
doesn't feel like over performance kind
of acting it's very sincere performances
and I was very much impressed very much
INSAT all that I was I was pretty
surprised about how I was in the shoes
of the Westerners and I was like man
this point even hits home harder that
it's 90 years later and we are still
these people you know I think that's
that's the funny part to me is like
these people are talking about that
they're portraying of the Westerners
still exist they're never gonna stop
existing and the times they're talking
about how the world will evolve and what
it will turn into you in a cynical way
it's happened this is the facts well and
around that time I'm sure you know
people were thinking that too you know I
feel like that is a message that that
keeps this film tight yes because I
think no matter I mean unless we happen
to achieve a utopian society any time
soon you'll always be able to look
around and be like yeah they were right
and they're still right oh yeah like
reading up on this people were like
laughing at this movie when it first
came out like there were scenes in here
that were serious that people just
laughed at and there were there were
moments here where I think I was
sitting here going to this get anybody
like blacklisted or did anybody get in
trouble cuz they're you know are some
like socialist ideas yeah you know and
that maybe a little bit before the time
but there's yeah a lot of that like
being free of you know capitalism in
personal possession i weirdly feel like
now it would be more if this movie came
out now it would be more accepted than
back then which is kind of funny yeah
yeah not like I mean if you made it like
a money in a weird way because they were
more of a culture that that it's more
Geron to the kind of ideas and messages
portrayed in this movie now as opposed
to back then yeah it's funny man right
anyway there's a great movie and David I
want to thank you for most stuck with me
it really has stuck with me and it's a
movie that a lot of people haven't heard
of - a lot of people haven't heard of
this movie I bring it up with showdown
people movie fights people and they're
like what's that Tina it's a forgotten
movie maybe because it was burned and
lost for a long time but you know
looking through some credentials other
than the National Register I was talking
about earlier it is on AFI is like a lot
of it's best 100 years100 movies hundred
years of film scores it's it's just it's
a treasure of a film and I really do if
you haven't seen a long time go re-watch
it and yeah having to sit through it go
watch it it is a very much ahead of its
time a very deep movie and a beautiful
and a beautiful sort of and a movie that
manages to have subtle conflict edits
bookends because it's funny when you're
out of shangri-la it's just a nightmare
it's like it whatever you're not sharing
a lot it's it's it's an exciting trip in
it's chaotic it's harsh not just in the
Himalaya Mountains we cycle in China
even when you're back in the country
like it's just like it's just a
different energy you know and then
shangri-la where you keep expecting
conflict is what we're conditioned to
there's no conflict
yeah just like conflict we created yeah
there's lots of room and space and air
and stuff you can feel it the
environment is felt yeah even within the
film and black and white it's felt I
found Zach Roman loved this
ah alright guys well thanks for sitting
through all this view or listening to
all this really appreciate what's it's
it's uh it's a classic film that you
feel like no one really regards anymore
it talks about the should be talked
about more putting the comments below
you guys can subscribe the reject nation
click that notification bell and check
us on patreon Pais